how are you going to trust a woman with
your children if she has a big tattoo
all over her chest what up guys welcome
to the just pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my whiteboard
videos today I am going to be talking
about five red flags and women now this
is just coming from my experience of
interviewing hundreds of women and you
know if I had a brother which I do I
have five this is the advice that I
would give them you know you guys can
take it or leave it but this is my two
cents before I start don't forget to
like the video as that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams so number one all
right this is really important chest
tattoos
or tattoos in really any big bulky
tattoos that can be easily seen and not
covered typically this means she's
spontaneous and not in a good way how
are you going to trust a woman with your
children if she has a big tattoo all
over her chest you know usually means
spontaneous usually a bit you
know just number two number two if she
has more than one baby daddy because my
question is not one not two now you're
looking for a third you know clearly
this is a woman that doesn't value
Commitment if she's got children with
two different men clearly she's a bit
irresponsible and clearly commitment is
not important to her and she values her
feelings over her children three if she
talks about horoscope this is important
this basically me when a woman
when a woman is constantly talking about
horoscopes Energies
I can't take accountability for my poor
decision so what'll happen is she'll
freak out you know on the show or in
life and she'll blame it on her star
sign you do not want a woman that is
blaming her poor decisions on her
horoscopes four gets work done bbl's
Botox lip fillers guys this all comes at
a cost that you will have to pick up
when you guys get together you know this
shows one the average woman makes like
35k a year so where are her priorities
if she's spending money on lip fillers
bbls Botox and at some point
are going to be the one to pick up that
bill and four it's just it's just not
the most honest like personally if I was
recommending a girl to my brother if a
girl's got heavy work done she's usually
insecure you know she usually will take
the easy way out instead of trying to be
healthier and get in better shape I just
I wouldn't you know tell a brother or a
guy I cared about to go for that five 35
Plus now this is not to say that all
women over 35 Plus would may be horrible
wives
um in fact there are some that would be
great wives and mothers the reason I
would tell my brother not to go for a
girl over 35 is because geriatric
pregnancy starts at 35 and if he wants a
wife every year it's going to be more
and more risky for them to have kids so
this is just my opinion right five red
flags and women that I would tell
someone I cared about not to go for
chest tattoos big No-No tattoos and you
know very seeable places multiple baby
daddies guys you don't want to be a
stepfather it's just not a good deal for
you horoscope getting a bunch of work
done bbl's lip filler and over the age
of 35 that's my advice guys take it or
leave it let me know what you think what
are the biggest red flags in women like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time